You know that response is like a lock, like you won. Jar is making
it sound insane. It's not insane. To be fair, Nick had the bigger
audience and the bigger stomach, so he was at a pretty big advantage
from the start.
>> That's crazy. Uh-oh. Uh-oh.
>> Stupid Turkey Tom gets falsely accused of it and everybody
else suffers. Trust me, Nick and Chud are just the [laughter]
tip of the iceberg. Not falsely accused of being a age player,
Just a robot? On Chud versus The Oreo? The chill [__]
slalom.
Uh daddy's home. Get ready for another exciting episode of Just
The Bot.
Hohohohoho. What is that? How did HE START WHY IS HE STARTING
IT LIKE THIS? What the
>> So, the drama community is in another civil war for
the 18th billionth time. It's basically between Chud Logic and
his supporters versus Nicholas DeOrio and his supporters. And
it all got started over the Turkey Tom allegations and H3H3.
No, I am not joking. I mean, this is true. Yeah, he absolutely
sold his bad idea. 100% I agree. Let's begin with a little background
starting with H3H3, aka Ethan Klein. Ethan is one of the most
well-known and oldest people in the drama community. This guy
has been making drama videos for over a decade now. He got into
a drama with LeafyIsHere and Pyrocynical. After that, he started
rubbing shoulders with some of the biggest people in the anti-SJW
community. Over time, he became more and more of a leftist and
disavowed a lot of the old anti-SJW videos he made. Unsurprisingly,
this caused a lot of people to turn against him. Several people
called him a snake and a liar during his drama with LeafyIsHere.
And now people were calling him a snake and a liar again. H3
became an enemy to Keemstar, several Leafy clones, anti-SJW,
anti-woke YouTubers, and even the commentary bros. Okay. But
luckily for Ethan, he was still chummy with a lot of breadtubers
such as Hasan [__] Podcasting with one another made
them both even more successful than they used to be. But then
a Hasan shocked his dog. Uh how I got that Hasan shocked his
dog. >> other side of the planet between backwards desert
people happened, and this caused the friendship of Ethan and
Hasan to end. Ethan then got into drama Isn't Jar You say this,
isn't Jar like openly a fart
And this guy And this guy like a big
fart huffing
deviant? with Hasan and his friends, and this caused all of his
old enemies to start joining him. Yep, you heard me right. The
commentary bros, the anti-woke YouTubers, and everything in between
all started backing H3H3 because they hated Hasan [__]
more. I guess Dude, did they put Dude, Ethan is Lucifer. Nicholas
is a is a demon at like a demonic cardinal.
AB is like John Wick for some reason. Is this more Pegasaur right
here? Sort of
I think that's who that is. And then
And over here we've got all of the holiest of holies. Denim's
Frogan.
Wait, who's this?
Who the [__] is this? I don't know who some of these
people are. Anisa, iDubbz. Who this?
Chris Kunsler? I don't know who that is. >> all started
backing H3H3 because they hated Hasan [__] more.
I guess the old thing is true. The enemy of my enemy is my buddy.
But there was one person in the commentary bros who backed H3
more than anyone else, and that was Saint Nicholas DeOrio, a
man even fatter than Santa Claus himself. You see, around this
time the Destiny drama was happening, and since Nick could no
longer orbit Destiny, he would orbit H3H3 instead. It's kind
of ironic that this big fat Jack Horner-looking is the one orbiting
people instead of the OTHER WAY AROUND. IDUBBZ WITH THE BULL.
>> SPEAKING of the Destiny drama, Chud Logic Dude, the
Okay, hold on. These guys
How long will it be until PPP realizes and turns and and starts
snarking Ethan? It's got to be in this year. They've got to do
it this year, right? I feel like it's got to happen. accused
Tom of being a sweeper right to his face. Yeah, we should wrap
this Destiny thing up though before we get completely flipped
and we don't actually engage with the
I mean, what are we supposed to say? We don't really know what
went on. Yeah, it's I guess that's kind of the main thing is
I don't really know what's going on. I mean, it's it's pretty
obvious [laughter] it's pretty obvious Okay, okay. Can we stop
this sweeping, please? It's pretty obvious what went on, isn't
it? What Okay, there wasn't No, wait, wait, wait. It's obvious,
bro. Wait, it's obvious, dude. Every time I see this clip and
I hear Augie in the background, I'm just like That's my guy.
I I ride with Augie.
>> Augie in the background. Just high-pitched as [__]
Donald Destiny. Donald Destiny in the back. I love it. Love it.
Love the energy. >> Chud Logic, let's talk about it. Chud
Logic, let's talk about it. What do you mean it's obvious? >> I
don't The sweeping is unbelievable. I heard it, but I didn't
know it was true. Tom sweeping with Destiny again, bro. Here
we go. Here we go. Not going to lie, this is pretty based, but
it did somewhat throw Tom and the others. Chud Logic every now
and then would take jabs at the other commentary bros, including
Nicholas DeOrio for sucking off Ethan >> I'm not bringing
up Nicholas DeOrio's stream. I'm not making it about anyone individual,
okay? I don't care about your gay camp. This is also really Do
you know what Do you know what Whilst we're here, I'll also say
this as well. I'm so sick of you utter cretins desperately trying
to throw a wedge between me and DeOrio because he's sucking Ethan
Klein at the moment, okay? I have got my issues with it, but
you guys are so You're like my brain with the [__]
that you're willing to do. The 20th stream sucking off Ethan
Klein. Yes, I'm talking about you, Nicholas DeOrio, >> Nick
confronted Chud in private about this, and they somewhat talked
things >> Now listen, I will be fair. I know what people
in chat thinking and they're going to say, okay? But my concern,
ladies and gentlemen, is the big sweep might be on, okay? The
mid I'm going to have to switch over and watch the bungee video
after this. To be honest with you.
We might have to. >> big sweep might be on. Gotta sweep,
sweep, sweep. >> I am not participating in the big sweep.
>> Yes, this was directed at Nick and the other commentary
bros. We know this because he said this right after reading out
a post from Nick. >> Nick just responded, "Oh, just to
be clear, I've seen literally nothing of what's occurred tonight,
but my understanding is that Half-Baked is on hiatus for a little
while, so we'll see in the next couple of days where that
I think Chud said in the DMs or whatever, "Yeah, this was Like
of course it was referencing you." He's like, "It was referencing
other people, too, but it was primarily referencing you." >> Nick
DeOrio states that Half-Baked is podcasting with Tom and Augie
going on hiatus for a while, but it could be DMs.
Here's the thing with this, okay? Anyone that wants to claim
that this is a nothing burger, why the [__] is the
podcast going on hiatus, dude? If this is nothing to worry about,
nothing to be concerned about, why is the podcast going on hiatus?
A few weeks later, Tom responded to these allegations and completely
proved himself innocent. Thanksgiving came a little early, but
this turkey was not on the menu. Around the same time, Chud was
going on vacation, and Nicholas DeOrio took a few jabs at Chud
Logic during his Turkey Tom coverage. Nicholas took a few more
jabs at Chud about halfway through his follow-up Turkey Tom video.
It was just him regurgitating stuff he said previously and also
clarifying a few things. Despite Nick not directly making a video
on Chud, just taking jabs at him in his Turkey Tom video, it
still caused Chud to lose roughly 600 subscribers. I want to
make it clear that neither Chud nor Nicholas has directly made
a video on the other person, at least not yet.
That's not true.
That's Like you mean like a concerted hit piece? That's like
an edited video? Maybe not. But they've definitely done full
live streams on each other. I don't know what Jar is saying here.
Like Chud absolutely did a live stream on Nick. Nick did at least
one live stream, maybe two on Chud. But when Chud came back from
vacation, he was
Up until that point in time.
No, no, I think I think Nick had done some stuff while Chud was
on vacation. >> than the US Vietnam vets. Nick DeOrio was
someone who looked pathetic for cutting off his friendship with
Chud publicly over such a small reason. Oh no, he said the big
sweep might be on. Now I understand that was not the only reason.
It was just the straw that broke the camel's back. It's kind
of like when you domestically abuse your partner over something
small like forgetting to buy tin foil at the store. Obviously,
that's something small that no one would attack another person
over, but that's not why you're actually doing it. You had it
coming for a lot of different reasons. But of course, the officer
is not going to see it that way. He's just going to come up to
you and say, "So, you um beat your wife over um tin foil? Are
you serious?" So, Chud did have an easy win here. Unfortunately,
like a Democrat candidate who has a clear path of victory right
in front of them, he refused to get out of his own way. And
is just like Joe Biden. That's so true. I hadn't thought about
that before, but Chud is exactly like Joe Biden is. >> He
spent a lot of time spurging at his own chat. You made an attack
when he was
I just couldn't remember, Peanut. I'm not sure on the timeline
if Nick did the whole stream while Chud was gone or if Nick basically
I know Nick got mad and was like like seething about Chud not
doing coverage while he was on vacation, but I think it was I
think he waited until he came back. And then Chud came back,
and they both talked and then they did videos on each other or
like a video in a response. What are you on about, dude? I think
that's the timeline. Do you not [__] get it? It's
so transparent. Bro, you commentary viewers literally should
be sent to the glue factory, bro. It is insane how >> There's
this insane narrative that's been perpetuated about me. None
of these have actually watched my coverage, and they're just
angry at me. How about addressing the questions people are asking
instead of just calling them What do you mean? I'm addressing
the questions, dude. I'm addressing all of
I'm malicious.
What do you mean? How I being What you
>> What do you mean, bro? What do you mean?
Huge tirade, dude. He talked a little Stop being in your feelings.
Okay, this is code, dude. He launched
>> the ranged
what, 40 minutes segment or something, I saw. Talking about me
and talking about me when I was on holiday, when I was away.
And it's all stuff he could have Okay, segment while he was on
>> about before I went away. Some people tried to defend
this by saying things like, "Oh, he was just playing things up.
He wasn't actually that upset." Well, guess what? Acting like
an idiot still makes you an idiot. Also, I really don't think
he was playing things up. Chud then came up with one of the most
paranoid, bizarre conspiracies I have heard in a very long time.
I I don't know if this I don't know if this is
You you probably have to keep it to yourself. It's one of those
things that like doesn't actually
it's like not actually bad or I don't even think he was like
Uh it quite that way. I'll have to listen to him say it again.
This is going to be the idea of the day. The idea that they deleted
the video to make sure make sure Chud was on vacation, right?
>> Tom intentionally delayed his response to serious allegations
so Nick could cover it and bash Chud while he was on vacation
so he couldn't immediately
Jar makes that sound really absurd, like they haven't coordinated
like that before. And like
I'm sorry, they all do drama stuff. When you When you see When
you see Tom's response
you know that response is like a lock, like you won. Like when
Tom has all of the evidence he has and he writes that response
and makes the video, if you watch that video you know
that it's a a lock. You It's over. Right? So, delaying it a day,
2 days, 3 days, 4 days, none of that matters. Not delaying it
a month would matter, but delaying it like 2, 3 days, yeah, not
even a big deal.
I know I know Nick has talked about that, Nick. I'm saying But
obviously when you say it you'd have to have some kind of evidence
or else
you kind of look skizzo. So, you shouldn't say it, probably.
But I'm saying that it's not even like an insane thing. Jar is
making it sound
It's not insane.
You are a sad, strange little man, and you have my pity. Farewell.
Bro, imagine having to wait for me to go away to talk about me.
What an insane amount of cowardice we've witnessed,
The Joolians have left, dude. They've all unsubscribed. They've
lost 600 subs since I've been on holiday, dude.
How is that malicious, bro?
I am responding. Dude, this idea that I'm some snake, this idea
that I'm some snake when people are waiting till I go on holiday
to start talking all this about me. Are you serious, dude? Literally,
what have I done wrong here?
What have I done wrong? He waited for Turkey Tom's response so
he could create this impression that I'd been undermined by it,
which is Dude. Chud Chud could have won a lot harder here if
he just came back and did the Anisa playbook, okay? Anisa just
rolled Nick cuz she just started calling him
Chud should have just come back and started like actually hitting
this guy. Instead of like soft little jabs just come back throwing
haymakers. Don't do the like, "Oh, he talked [__]
about me while I was on vacation." Just be like, "Oh, you want
to talk shit?"
Here it is, man. It's ridiculous. As you'll see in a minute,
okay?
And then he obviously It's probably like always bad I do this,
too, so I can't even I can't even blame Chud. But it's probably
like always bad to talk about what you're annoyed about instead
of just responding directly.
Right? Like I'm annoyed with you, so I'm going to talk [__]
about you instead of saying, "Well, here's why I'm annoyed at
him." You just come on start talking [__] And then
you wait for a chatter to say something. Then a chatter says,
"Wait, why are you mad at this guy?" You go, "This piece of [__]
did this." Then you start you bring it up.
You know what I'm saying? waited >> Keep going. until I
was away so that he could launch his attack against me, right?
Say all the [__] that you wanted to say >> trying
to save the bridge at this point. That's over with bridge burn,
and then not have to deal with any of the
What's pathetic, bro? What is truly
is waiting till I go on holiday to talk all this [__]
about me, and then when I come back and respond, you're sat in
your Discord of
seething about me. What you've been doing for months. Like you've
been doing for months, apparently. Yet Chud logic and his fans
have this weird thing about his vacation, acting like you can't
make a video on him or respond to anything while he's away. You
knew know that Chud can just respond right when he gets back,
right? Responding to something immediately or a week later doesn't
Well, I think I think the allegation that Chud's annoyed about
is that he avoided covering Tom's response or something, that
he wasn't like
he wasn't fast to Tom's response. I think they were implying
that Chud was like scared to cover Tom's response.
Because he was on But not adding in that he was on vacation,
right? I'm pretty sure that's like what was annoying. Was he
Chud came back and was like, "Oh, well, why didn't Chud I thought
this is the big sweep. Now I think Chud's sweeping, actually."
And Chud came back was annoyed that it wasn't like like Nick
obviously knew he was on vacation. really change anything. Acting
like I was doing something sus when responding while Chud was
on vacation
is one thing. Granted, I didn't know the guy was
>> Uh-oh.
stupid take that a lot of his enemies noticed. >> I'm a
big fan of Nicholas DeOrio. What can I say? You do your research.
>> I wonder who noticed this one. I don't know. Not only
is that offensive, it's also bad. Like it's a bad impression.
Call E G Welkers. I'm sure happy that the guy with the ultimate
review hat is telling us what is and isn't offensive. He tried
to walk back on this saying he was making a hypocrisy argument,
which is completely post hoc cope. You would not get that implication
by watching this clip or the following clip after it. If anyone's
the hypocrite here
I pointed that out in a reply to Augie. He ignored me. Son of
a [__] Nicholas He was saying that it's too offensive
to make fun of someone's voice while wearing an ultimate review
hat. And the best part is Nicholas in the past also made fun
of Hila's voice and the way she looked. No, but did you hear
Tommy do the Hila Klein voice and [__] like that?
He did that today. You guys give this
Tommy gets under and goes Yeah, Keemstar, so maybe you should
start being a little bit nicer. That's the way it works. Tell
me something. Yeah, we're going to get Tommy to start doing the
voice. I still don't understand why Tommy's Israel voice is racist.
I don't
I do find it kind of funny sometimes that these guys have been
doing YouTube for so long. It's like, "Yeah, let's go let's go
hold these 16-year-olds accountable for the things they said."
Or maybe it's just the voices. Maybe Augie's like 24 here and
he just sounds 16. I don't know. Possible for him to Possible.
I was in the military and now I am wondering why Keemstar is
so mean to people. They look like children, though. Let's be
real. >> Hila Klein actually sounds like that. So, the
my officers and like the the soldiers in that brigade,
um they would go every night on a raid. Right. In Ramallah, there
were a lot of
And um so I always saw them preparing for it and leaving. And
then I I would stay in the base. So one time I wanted to go with
them.
It's funny cuz it's true. Of course, Nicholas has also done this
to other people like XQC, who has one of the most bizarre speaking
patterns I've ever heard in my life. Imagine going to XQC and
you're like, "Hey dude, what are you going to cover today?"
of the H3 people, Nicholas
So Oh [__]
Start Canadian? Maple Leafs and Okay, Nicholas
Who else?
Nick, Ethan, all these people
totally sweep this fact that XQC was the guy who was the most
egregious copyright violator and how pissed how
Well, sorry, this isn't XQC. But how
how Ethan was at XQC specifically
during this whole copyright drama, which was back here.
they totally ignore it and Ethan had the opportunity to sue X
for the same [__]
And they just they just totally dropped the ball. They didn't
do anything didn't do anything, okay?
With regards to the whole copyright thing, it makes them look
totally disingenuous and they have to take the L on this. When
Ethan goes to sue people, XQC steals his thumbnail, repackages
the content the exact way Ethan described being like malicious
and evil to do.
And XQC doesn't do [__] about it. Or sorry, Ethan
doesn't do [__] about it. But I'm pretty sure you
guys have heard this point plenty of times already. But I have
a unique point of my own about how much Nicholas sucks off Ethan
Klein. Nicholas doesn't like me. The dude has made dozens upon
dozens of videos about me. He'll even bring me up in videos that
have nothing to do with me. Like this video he made on that one
Christian Speaking of this stuff, damn, the JAR videos do good
for Dude, that's crazy.
The JAR videos go so hard. What the hell? Bunch of 100k videos
for JAR stream segments?
What the heck? What? Huh?
That's so much money. What the hell? Or sorry, that Well, it's
so much money. So many views. I can't believe that. Cuz I was
looking at Nicholas's segments and I'm like, "Damn, he gets like
20, 30k a video. This is crazy." And the JAR stuff is all massive.
Oh, but I was going to Well, I paused here to ask Is the Otterly
Noa stuff good? I honestly thought it like I'd heard it was boring,
so I didn't even bother looking into it. I understand the first
conversation was like kind of good. He's obviously
But it's like he's obviously plagiarizing. He kind of seems weaselly.
I don't know. I did Maybe the content was good, but I I saw it
was like blowing up and I'm like, "Mhm, is it really good?"
Pure coal? A lot of people been saying pure coal. But I'm sitting
here like
Bro, I I see people saying it's pure
But also, apparently Nicholas and Dickers went on E-Fap for it
or something. An Otter weaselly No way.
Very road to Mike. Fart into it? No, I just farted. Spicy hot
diarrhea?
Ooh, okay, yeah. Now, this is Dude, this is like POV JAR's DMs.
Or this video he made on the alt-right playbook guy, where he's
and moaning about no longer being motivated to make YouTube videos
right after he begging so much that he made enough money to pay
off his taxes. Why is this video so ugly? Why is it just like
spread text? What is >> for signs. Like random BoJack Horseman
footage behind You will find them. Dude, this is like a 40-minute
video. It's ass ugly. Be thankful that you're watching It's catharsis.
But you are the author, not the universe. You narrativize It's
art. No, dude, this is this is fart, >> is the path. It's
fart tent, not art >> And that's how you write your future.
Can you believe this video is being uploaded on the same channel
as like not the same channel, but like the same platform where
Just A Robot posts? And I actually don't know which video is
more pathetic. I don't know which video of mine Nicholas is referring
>> Why is JAR just seething about Nicholas talking [__]
about him? Why did this need to be included? He's being very
vague about it, but I think I totally love I know he was like
caviating like, "And I'm no fan of Nicholas cuz Nicholas is talk
me." And then he just had eight clips ready to go of Nicholas
talking
Like one would have sufficed. I get it. >> This guy is
a little bit more pathetic than me. But why am I bringing all
of this up? Is it to Why is he just so mean to me? Ha. No, I'm
bringing it up to show that he hates almost every single video
I make. He'll constantly bring me up and that he'll never agree
with me on anything. Unless, of course, I'm defending Ethan Klein.
If I go after Ethan's detractors like iDubbz, Nicholas will still
find a way to disagree with me. But if I'm defending Ethan directly,
like in my video on Cruel World Happy Mind, Nicholas absolutely
loves it. Sure, he talked about me at the start of the video,
but once we get to the parts of me defending Ethan Klein, he
will give me praise upon praise upon praise. I was exactly as
edgy in my iDubbz video as I was in this video. But because I'm
defending H3, Nicholas is forced to defend me. After all, Nicholas
is a good boy and he wouldn't do anything daddy wouldn't like.
Stop it. Get some help. After being wrecked for a while and not
being able to worm her way out of responsibility, she just kind
of laid down and took a stern talking to, like she was a daughter
getting disciplined by her parents for sleeping with too many
guys. She kept repeating her points, talking about personal [__]
and saying that she has to be better moving forward. This is
like the edgiest video that I've watched in a really long time
and it's breaking my mind that it's just a robot. Look at ALL
THAT CAPE. NO!
POP [__] ON the Dude, this is insane. This is I Dude,
I'm sorry.
This section is like way This Dude, you could cut so much out
of this section. This section sucks. He Like every other thing
that was in here, all you need to do is say what your arguments
were, why they weren't necessarily good, or why he was wrong
on him criticizing you in the iDubbz video. I get no context
here. You're just like, "Well, like how For all I know, JAR was
a total [__] in the iDubbz content and was actually
making really good arguments to defend Ethan in this one. I have
no idea what Ethan did in this one. I do wonder if Ethan is capable
of making good arguments himself. But Crazy. I I'm actually kind
of nervous to hear what he's going to say about Adam McIntyre.
walls. This guy's room or booth or whatever literally looks the
same as a 14-year-old girl's. I mean, he's right. And I know
this because a long time ago, I had a friend whose sister's room
looked exactly like this.
I totally thought JAR was going to be like I talked to a Discord
girl who had a room just like this. I swear that's where I thought
JAR was going with that. I was very concerned for a second. Dude,
this is [__] Jesus embarrassing. Basically, he says
some [__] that amounts to something something I started
a war I couldn't win or something something I'm a victim and
also gay. Jesus
Christ, JAR.
>> Holy Dude, I didn't expect this. This is like Unironically,
this is >> Nicholas infinitely funnier than this video
that he tried to make on iDubbz. I did not expect this. I'll
say if you [__] a girl with a room like this, you're
significantly less of a than Turkey Tom, okay?
Not that Turkey Tom is, but in terms of you're going to say somebody's
a likely to be a because of the room of the girl
This room, whoever has this room, significantly less bad than
the Tom one, okay? I'm just I'm just saying. I'm just saying.
I'm just saying. >> more to provide the most accurate information.
What do you mean your research is getting I truly believe Tom
is not a and he just engages in consensual age play, okay? Which
I don't even have a problem with, so long as he doesn't advertise
it and he doesn't like talk about how it's good.
Totally fine with that, all right? Was it worse before? I'm not
watching this old videos and this hard. >> You know how
bad things have to be that JAR understands this?
I will say JAR is doing a good job and I don't know if he even
understands the reasons why. JAR is making like awful jokes.
The points aren't that funny. It is just Nick laughing because
you're like on his side. He's shucking it up. He's shucking a
JAR bit, okay? He's doing his minstrel show. Oh, he took Ethan's
side?
>> I love when people defend Ethan Klein. This is something
This doesn't get through to like
Just A Robot has figured it out. That's crazy.
I'm shocked at how much this this This is killing me. This is
actually his best This is his best video he's ever made. And
there his arm goes. He even titled his original stream on this
something along the lines of JAR's redemption arc before he changed
it. Obviously, he did this because his fans wouldn't stop tearing
him apart. Bro is to Dude, this guy likes This guy likes sucking
farts. You can't take his side. You can't say he's redeemed.
>> The audience captured. Now, you could make the argument
that maybe Nicholas DiOrio just really liked this specific video
of mine. Yeah, out of the 10-plus videos of mine he has covered
and gave a negative review of, he just so happened to like the
one where I was defending H3H3.
What a coincidence. >> Wow. Now, this is a very common
pattern of behavior with Nick. When he likes another YouTuber
and becomes friends with them, if anyone attacks them in any
way, he becomes a sensitive little about it. He acts like an
anime YouTuber after someone said something negative about So
that's why I'm going to show this clip from DeAngelo Wallace.
Probably the best of which was the YouTuber Nicholas DiOrio telling
me that he unpins my comment on his YouTube video because I'm
I'm just as bad as I'm Alex. I get what he's trying to imply,
but I'm Alex falsely accuse somebody of assault. So, that's like
comparing apples to oranges. And besides,
unpinning a comment, that's the best you could come up with?
Okay. What do you think was going through Nicholas's mind when
he posted this tweet? I don't like this guy anymore. He's going
after my friend. You know what? I'm going to unpin his comment
and I'm going to tell him that I did it. >> Yeah, that
will show him. What a zinger Okay. Okay.
At risk of doing the exact thing Jar is Nicholas is doing. That
is funny, okay?
I have to let you know that I unpinned your comment from my video.
He is cute. He might as well send DeAngelo to heaven with that
one. Now, for the very few of you who don't know the context
as to what's going on. Basically, DeAngelo called Turkey Tom
racist for saying that he wanted to kill all the Tiggers, but
replace the T in the word Tiggers with the letter N. Acting like
I was calling Tom a Nazi and a white nationalist. I called him
racist for saying I hate
It's not that serious. Of course, Nick ran to Tom's defense and
this escalated to the point where he was accusing DeAngelo of
some wild [__] I think the worst tweet out of all
though was this one right here. Once again from Nicholas DeOrio.
Send your audience, tell them I said things I didn't, have them
flag my Twitter down like you're clearly trying to do with Tom.
Oh, [__]
Is DeAngelo Wallace swinging his audience into Nicholas DeOrio?
Not good, man. That's pretty [__] dog. Don't do that.
What the hell? First of all, if I did somehow get his Twitter
taken down, you realize literally everyone would hate me, right?
Secondly, if me tweeting about someone and tagging them in the
tweet is me trying to get their account taken down, then that
means everyone tweeting about me right now is trying to take
my account down. Does that make literally any sense whatsoever?
You're just putting words in my mouth and it makes you seem really
dumb. Nicholas DeOrio has a habit of commenting on other people's
relationships like I dubs relationship, other people's relationship,
and even my relationship. Uh-oh. Uh-oh. Tonka saw clip incoming.
OH, NO. DIDN'T HE SAY THAT HIS girlfriend was going to dump him
if he makes a drama video? That's weird. My last five videos
have been drama adjacent and she's still with me. I feel it.
I I sense it. I don't do ultimatums in relationships.
Of course, if Nick wants to talk about other people's relationship,
then he's more than welcome to. But, if you're going to throw
stones, you shouldn't live in a glass house. Nick, you have some
nerve commenting on a relationship. Last I checked, your love
life is a pile of My last video was on internet blood sports.
It's probably my best video ever and you guys should totally
check it out. The reason I bring this up is because I had to
do a lot of research into different YouTubers, one of which was
Tonka Saw, and I found this clip between him and Nicholas DeOrio.
Tonka, when did the tears come out of my eyes? I was crying.
When did the tears come out of your eyes? Probably when that
girl said she wasn't your girlfriend on that post. That was the
saddest [__] I've ever seen. What girl said she wasn't
my girlfriend? When you posted a picture of you holding somebody's
hand, just trying to be vague about it and then they're like,
"You have a girlfriend?" And the girl's like, "No, no, no. He's
my best friend." Did you have no idea what you're talking about?
That was funny as [__] >> No, that was funny
as [__] Okay, so that didn't happen, Nick. Nick,
did that happen or not? Yeah, it absolutely happened. You posted
a vague picture of you holding somebody's hand or like some [__]
and then they're like, "Do you have a girlfriend?" She's like,
"No, no, no. He's my best friend and not my girlfriend." You
don't talk about my [__] personal life on here. I
don't your personal life. It's a tweet he made. It's a tweet
you made, Nick. Nick, it's a tweet you made. That's not your
personal life. Do not [__] It's a tweet you made.
It's not your personal life. It's a tweet, not your personal
life, dork. Oh, wow. You think it's cool to talk like I I I intentionally
don't
>> THIS IS SUCH AN INSANE coat move from Nicholas. He does
this sometimes. Wow. Wow. Wow.
>> Shut up, man. Nick, it's a tweet you made. That's not
your personal life. Do not It's a tweet you made. It's not your
personal life. It's a tweet, not your personal life, dork. Oh,
wow. You think it's cool to talk like I I I
Wow. Wow. Wow. You think it's cool to talk about my personal
life? I actually don't name people like this specifically cuz
I keep that part of my life very off the internet. No, you don't.
You try to post it and look cool and you didn't look cool. It
was her idea to make the post in the first place. I told him
I was I'm sure it was. She did. That's none of your [__]
business. Then why'd you post it on Twitter, Nick? It's none
of my business. It's none of my business. Why is it up there,
Nick? Why'd you post it if it's none of anybody's business? All
you guys have is looking into people's personal lives and How
is this your personal LIFE, NICK? YOU POSTED IT TO DEBATE, TONKA.
Because it's funny. Remember? It's about things that are funny.
We're debating.
We're debating, Nick. Is that what's
Oh, did Nick Bro just rage quit. Nicholas DeOrio has made entire
videos commenting on It's just totally crazy that Nick tried
to take that line, right? It's totally insane that Nick tried
to to to walk that line of you can't talk about other people's
personal lives.
And like you just No shot. He He doesn't believe that. He's never
believed that. Dude. Other people's relationships. But, as soon
as he gets pressured on one of his relationships, he rage quits.
Bro is absolutely [snorts] a glass cannon. He can dish it out,
but he can't take it. I really do love how he tries to shift
the blame and say, "Oh, it's her idea." Bro, she was the one
who commented on it to correct the record. For context, Nicholas
DeOrio posted this picture of him with a girl at VidCon. Aw,
they're clinking glasses together. How romantic. Probably the
closest Nick ever got to first base. Some guy replied to this
tweet with, "I guess you have a girlfriend." The girl in question
replies to this tweet with, "We aren't dating, but he's my best
friend." Oh, friend zoned. And Nicholas DeOrio replied with,
"We aren't dating, but he's my best friend."
No, friend. Just never seen that before. And Nicholas DeOrio
replied with,
Women. To everybody watching this video, do you guys think this
was her idea because it really doesn't look that way to me. Who
knows? Maybe it was her idea so she could publicly humiliate
Nick. I do love how triggered he gets over people talking about
his personal life, a personal life he made public himself when
he has literally done 10 times worse to multiple different people.
I have to wonder, do you guys think that Nick gets any like any
at all? Dude probably gets less than I do and I'm just a robot.
He said it. He said it. Jar is more than Nick. Elon predicted
we would be having sex with robots by 2025. When do you
>> that's crazy?
I'm sorry. It's crazy that he's sitting here and talking about
how much more he thinks what it's like.
I don't know.
Nothing. Nothing. Just this guy.
Like what is People will have sex with I'm going to keep going.
I I want to make jokes with the fart thing, but he's winning
so I'm not going to do it. The year 2025.
Nick, if you're watching this, let me give you some dating advice.
Yes, you are going to get dating advice from Mr. Jay himself.
First, get into her DMs and then ask her if she wants to see
a picture of your [__] And then after that, send
her a picture of a chicken. This is foolproof. It's never failed
once. You know, maybe this is why Nick is batting so hard for
Ethan Klein. A lot of the girls on his subreddit seem to think
that Nick is hot. Oh, no.
Jar is going to the Jar is going to the wine moms. Jar is going
to hit Nicholas in the wine moms. Oh, no. The pity.
The pity comments from the wine moms because of the Anisa clips.
Oh, no. Maybe selling out for a is the only way for this dude
to get But, Nicholas DeOrio sleepy to think that Nick is hot.
Maybe selling out for a is the only way for this dude to get
Many such cases. But, Nicholas DeOrio sleepy time calls at VidCon
are not his only stories he has for VidCon. I need to come clean
about something. I told a lot of people that I was working on
a video about Bowblax, but as I was working on it, I kind of
got bored and just made a video on internet blood sports. So,
sorry, everyone. I'm no longer making that video on Bowblax.
But, as I was doing research for that video, I came across this
clip. For context, after Nick and Bowby's falling out where Nick
completely destroyed Bowblax, a few of Bowblax's friends confronted
Nicholas DEORIO AT VIDCON.
ONE OF THEM WAS NET LOSS and he's
Oh, god.
Bro, Jar getting revenge on everybody. It's too bad this video
only has 2K views cuz he's getting revenge on everybody. Nicholas
DeOrio's $600
So, I walked up to him and I introduced my We did We did all
these clips on stream at at some point. I go, "I'm the bad Nick
that you're saving everybody from." He goes, "What?" I go, "You
know, you're you're saving all these Nicks out there. I'm the
one that you're saving them from or something." And he goes,
"Oh, I'm not shaking your hand." He owned [laughter] you. And
then he No, but then he gets right in my face and he goes, "You
know, if I had a nickel for every time a drama YouTuber freaked
out over a handshake at VidCon, I would have two nickels, which
isn't a lot, but it's weird that it's happened twice. He's like,
"I don't like you." And I'm like, >> okay." Like, "So,
wait. What are you going to do about it?"
Does Jar Jar needs the art chat stream. If Jar doesn't have the
art chat stream, this is not a win.
Jar officially loses if he does not have the art chat stream
cuz it's required viewing for this section. He's like, "I just
called him a slur." You better have [laughter] it. I'm like,
"You're acting like a slur right now." Oh, thank god. Nick only
called him an acronym for a freaky alien genotype. At least he
didn't make fun of the guy's voice because that would have been
a step too far. I'm joking. Of course, Nick still made fun of
the guy's voice, who actually sounds like this in real life.
You see this light down here? It's an automatic AI light. It
tracks me. I got an automatic tracking crew, right? And it's
shaking its head at me as I film this video. It clearly must
have sensors in it that are like, "Oh, no, no, no, no, no. Don't
talk about data collection." But, data collection is what they
do. Not that thing. But, other things definitely do. >> Nick
can say what he wants about Anisa's impression of Hela, but it
was way more spot-on than his impression of Net Loss. Honestly,
now I'm starting to think that he just took offense to the fact
that she's better at doing impressions than
>> So, he snatched my glasses off my face and started dancing
seductively at me. So, I followed him for like 2 seconds and
I realized he's not turning around and then I walked back. >> So,
Net Loss literally went up to Nicholas Deorio and ripped his
sunglasses off his face. If someone did that to me or most men
I know, I would just beat the [__] out of them. And
yeah, that would be in your legal
Is Jarf is is Jar a fight on sight kind of guy?
I don't I don't know if I believe that, man. >> takes something
off of you, that can legally be classified as assault. Yes, I
did learn that from Legal Eagles' worst video. They're prescription.
You can have them back. I'm like, "Yeah, thanks for my $600 glasses."
And Yeah, but if you were if you were to go like take my glasses
or he did, then he's just going to get smacked, bro. That's not
my fault, that's your fault. You got to understand, I'm in like
an aura right now. Like Yeah, that's not how that went down.
Nick probably said, "Oh, will you please give them back? They're
my prescription glasses." And Net Loss, feeling bad for the blind
bat, gave him his glasses back. Nick, if you're watching this
video, seriously, man, why would you even tell people this story?
It makes you sound like a little Come on. Come on. Come on. >> prescription
glasses. Where's the aura? Where's the He doesn't have the Archad
clips? Bro.
About here? Roundabout here? Right? Roundabouts here, okay. >> a
funny story.
VidCon, okay?
This is This is another guy who's at that party telling the story
from a maybe slightly less biased perspective 9 months ago. Let's
go.
VidCon, Turkey Tom's rager at VidCon. I'm frozen. All right,
I'm frozen? Cool.
>> Cool. Turkey Tom's rager at VidCon.
So, Tom threw a big party >> in this skate >> Archad.
Uh they they this skate shop with this indoor like mini ramp
and like street session set. It was like a warehouse for a a
skateboard brand.
we're all there. So,
the commentary people, the commentary people there, and Nicholas
Deorio shows up. Okay, Nicholas Deorio shows up. So, Oki and
Nicholas Deorio have beef. Oki's weird stories and Nicholas Deorio
have a have a public beef, and they have for a long time. So,
Got it. when I walk in,
uh Oki
and Dan Tavius
are pressing
Deorio because everyone they're all still friends with Bowblax.
And uh I've like I've talked about Lex a few times. Nice guy.
It's totally criminal that look, man,
guy's in his mid-20s. If he wants to cross-dress, who gives a
[__] Okay?
If That is not a valid opinion in the commentary community.
I will admit Bobby also
Uh whatever. It's fine. You know what? You know what? I'm going
to take a brave position and say he's in his mid-20s. If the
man wants to cross-dress, let him have his way, okay? I'm going
to I'm going to I'm going to wrap back around and just say, "You
know what? True. Let the man cross-dress. What's the harm?" >> If
Bowblax
wants to cross-dress
as an adult man, look, he's in the commentary sphere. He's going
to get dragged through the
Uh and and maybe he should have expected to get dragged through
the mud for his uh for his online I'll be real, though. OnlyFans
was a step too far. Mr.
a step too far. As much as I like Bowblax now, okay? As much
as I think Bowblax, you know, he dealt with all this after the
fact a little better than I expected.
I Dude, the OnlyFans was too far, okay? behavior with the cross-dressing.
But who cares? Who gives a [__] Okay? I don't give
a goddamn. Anyway, you have
who is this all the all this guy talks about is this uh this
other man
and uh his his decisions in his adult
Okay? Dirtbag.
That is a lot of what Deorio talks about. Total dirtbag. Dirtbag.
It's all he talks about. It's all he streams about is Bowblax
and why Bowblax is a you know, he's just making a lolcow out
of Bowblax.
Right? So,
Oki, who already doesn't like Deorio, presses Deorio. He goes
up and he goes like, you know,
Bowblax is like really depressed.
Um how would you feel if like Bowblax off? Like, you know, you're
basically like
you're you're you're you're basically just uh you know, bull
like cyberbullying this guy into like complete depression over
like over nothing. Like, he didn't do anything to you. He's just
existing on the [__]
>> And then Net Loss
Net Loss walks up
and uh beefs Nicholas Deorio.
So, he he walks up. I I see this all. I didn't I wasn't uh I
didn't talk to Deorio. I walked up to him. I walked up to Deorio.
And then I was like realized who it was and I thought, "I don't
want to talk to this guy. I don't even want to like instigate
uh with this dude." So, so like the picture you're getting painted
here
Tom's got his cool friends that he invites to his party, okay?
That's Archad, that's like the cooler YouTubers who have, you
know, something they have something they do that builds an audience
that isn't just purely, you know, taking one of your best friends
and turning them into a lolcow so you can torture them on stream,
which has been a lot of Nick's content over the All right? Not
that it's necessarily like evil to do that, but it's like he's
got a habit of doing it. It's he's just a weirdo. Also, I just
generally get the feeling like he's kind of off-putting in personal
interactions with people. So, Tom's got his cool friends and
Nick is there. And this Archad guy is like, "This guy's an ass."
And he starts like walking near him or he he he maybe senses
something about this guy. He starts walking near him and goes,
"Oh, that's Nicholas Deorio. Oh, he is an ass, but I don't even
uh I'm just going to I'm just going to I'm going to go back to
the party."
>> The aura Nicholas puts out, okay? >> that they're
talking to to all of Tom's cool friends.
Nicholas is a loser to all of Tom's cool new friends, the people
he actually wants to hang out with, all right? >> Deorio,
and then I walk away.
Net Loss walks up behind me and uh tells Deorio to his face he
doesn't like him. And Deorio is like, but Deorio sticks his hand
out to shake Net Loss's hand. And Net Loss says, "I'm not shaking
your hand. I don't like
And then takes Deorio's sunglasses off his face. By the way,
look, Deorio is a short, fat [__] okay?
Deorio is a short, fat >> Bow and Bow's legs, yeah. >> 5'6"
maybe, and he's very big.
>> Yeah? And so, Deorio Net Loss takes the sunglasses off
Deorio's face and puts them on and then starts dancing away.
And and and dances and like Deorio goes to like chase him, but
like he can't. Okay. I can just see like the aura loss. Like,
there's just nothing Nick could do, right? This like tall, cool
guy who runs a cool channel takes his sunglasses, starts like
dancing away, and Nick like kind of half-waddles after him. can't
chase him. So, Nick just like has his sunglasses on and dances
away. Anyway, Deorio has told this story like
uh two or three times on stream, and he keeps characterizing
Net Loss
as like I'm sure people in the chat have seen Net Loss's videos.
Um he keeps characterizing Net Loss as like a tiny
uh geeky guy. And he's like, "Oh, this tiny guy this tiny guy
game came up to me and was like, "You're Nicholas Deorio. I don't
like you." Which is not what which is not what Net Loss sounds
like at all. If you've seen his videos, he has like a deeper
voice than me. And he's as tall as me. We're both like 6 ft tall.
So, just the fact that like Deorio keeps telling this story
on his streams
and also
is um you know, characterizing Net Loss as as like a as a as
a caricature that he's like not at all. And anybody who knows
him or seen his videos can like clearly clearly disprove any
of the characterizations that uh that Deorio has given Net Loss
is hilarious. And also, every time Deorio is told this story,
every time Deorio is told this story, he says that he called
Net Loss a which he didn't do. >> Well, oh wait, I'm not
on Twitch. Thank you. Okay. Disavow, but we're on Twitch, so
TOS, we're all good. Dude, I'm I'm very trigger-happy with the
Twitch stuff now, okay?
Let's go. He No, sorry. He said he said I called him I dubs'
favorite slur. So, I don't know if that's the n-word
>> But he keeps saying that he called Net Loss a slur,
which he didn't. Like, he didn't call him a slur. He's like tells
this story as if like, "Oh,
this tiny guy walked up to me and was really geeky and annoying,
and then I then I called him the n-word."
Is this the n-word? >> with all these people in like these
huge glass bottles of like mineral water or
I feel like I'm seeing this more and more. It's just crazy.
Sam Hyde or something? >> Why would you lie about calling
someone a slur? Because he wants to be edgy. Because he's like,
"Oh, I have to be This is cool. This my my perception of being
cool
is uh Yeah, he talked about this on the Half-Baked podcast. No,
it's really
Cuz his perception of being cool Okay, I will give you guys this.
Archad does talk in circles a little bit. All right, he's not
telling the story perfectly.
But he's chilling. He's vibing. He's having a good time. >> Cool.
Is being like this tough Long Island dude who uh you know, wears
a Rolex
and uh and talks about um He's like my $600 sunglasses.
I get that you hang out with JJ McCullough, but don't do the
lie that we say a boot. Are you good? Are you good? Do you hear
that? >> And uh and talks about um God, no.
He's like my $600 sunglasses.
All right, he's just his his perception of being cool is just
being this edgy Long Island dude who calls people the N-
And in actuality, he's a short, fat who who's bullying his old
friends into like
God, what a abhorrent person, man. I don't know, it's so crazy
that
it's uh it's it's so crazy that you can the slur-slinging larper.
It's too funny to not even have the balls to say the slur. I
know, man. Like you're hanging out like Turkey Tom is I don't
No one there gives a them a You've not heard me say a boot. Shut
up.
Think H3 will be able to go get through to Kino Casino about
their use of the F-slur. Ethan has a real problem with it apparently
despite being a huge fan of a huge Kino fan.
I hope he tried I just hope he tries to like message PPP and
have some sort of interaction with him. I Anything Ethan can
do to like rustle that beehive, that nest of hornets, okay? I
absolutely want him to shake that nest. Anything he can do to
annoy PPP in any way, please do. [__] commentary
YouTubers. You think if you say you're going to get in trouble
at the [__]
at the at the commentary party?
Anyway, funny as [__] Look, I feel like I feel like
people stay people say stay close to him cuz he's a demon.
Cuz I know he's friends with uh he's friends with like Waybaby
Webserf
and uh Tom and some of those other people. And like what is that?
If Nick is a demon to these people,
I just I'm sitting here I'm like, dude, Nick is like the softest
like cry-bullyist person that I know. Like out of all the YouTubers
I've had like personal interactions with, I feel like Nick is
the biggest cry bully of
I would never think of him as like a demon. I It's crazy. I I
just can't
like compared to the sphere of people I hang out with, this is
nothing. I understand why you would want him why you wouldn't
want him as an enemy.
Uh because he will like unapologetically
uh you know, double-cross you any second Okay, that's true. That's
true. >> right? If it be if it can become content, he will
do it. I think that's good enough for the Our Chad stuff. Also,
outside of ArgiaRFC, Turkey Tom, Nicholas DeOrio, and Bo Black,
no one gives a [__] about Tipster. A common complaint
about me is that I bring up past dramas too often. Shut the [__]
up. Nicholas DeOrio is 10 times worse than me. If you look up
Nicholas DeOra on YouTube, you'll see more people making videos
on him now than probably ever before. But it seemed like most
people sided with him in his fight with Bo Black or his fight
with Chud Logic. So, what happened? Well, it's because Nick was
cozying up to H3H3. A lot of people do love the guy, but a lot
of people also hate him. And thanks to Nick's little roll in
the mud with Chud Logic, which also made a lot of the other commentary
bros turn on Nick as well, who does Nick really have in his corner
anymore? Well, there's Augie and that's about it. Drama YouTubers
are sharks and currently there's blood in the water. I honestly
feel like Augie doesn't even agree with Nicholas on the points.
I feel like Augie is just out of a sense of loyalty going to
keep He's going to go down with the Nick ship. Like Nick was
his friend a long time ago.
I got I just get this feeling in my stomach that Augie doesn't
even necessarily agree with him on the points at all and knows
that Nick is wrong and is just like, yeah, okay, he's my friend
and I don't even make content that much anyway, so I'll just
go down with my friend. Nick is currently avoiding the drama
surrounding him. >> man. Meaning that his low cow gene
hasn't really quite activated yet. He still has a very good chance
of turning everything around and getting out of this mess. Even
as I'm recording this, people are still making more videos on
Nick. Pointing out the fact that as soon as Anisa Chomos start
talking about him, he stopped covering her >> No I don't
say April.
who only goes after low-hanging fruits. To be fair, To be fair,
To be fair, To be fair, With how fat and short he is, I think
he can only reach the low-hanging fruits. Ultimately, most of
the stuff people have against Chud and Nick is pretty small potatoes.
Yeah, Chud took a pretty nasty hit to his view and sub counts,
but he's already starting to get back into the algorithm. Nick
hasn't really taken any damage at all and he's kind of just ignoring
everything. Think about what other streamers like Vaush, Destiny,
and Hasan have done. They're doing perfectly fine and they have
done way more [__] than both Nicholas DeOrio and
Chud Logic combined. I do think it's absolutely hilarious that
Turkey Tom gets falsely accused of and everybody else suffers.
Trust me, Nick and [laughter] Chud are just the tip of the Not
falsely accused of being a uh age player though.
And still everybody else suffers. Tom suffers not one iota. Not
not even a tiny bit.
a girl in a child's outfit
and he got away with it, okay? He got away with it. It's crazy.
>> But that's a video for another time. But let's be honest,
he didn't get away with it by himself. He had some help from
one of the subjects of this video, okay? The big sleep might
be on